- In this video, we're gonna
talk about spectroscopy,
which is all about the interactions
between light and matter.
And when we're talking about light,
we're not just talking
about visible light,
We're talking about electromagnetic
radiation in general.
And so what I'm going to do
to give us an intuition here
is use the PhET simulator by
the University of Colorado.
I encourage you to go to this URL
and try it out for yourself.
But you can see what the simulator does is
it allows us to essentially
see how different wavelengths
of electromagnetic radiation
can interact with matter,
in this case various molecules.
And just to get our bearings,
we can click on this
light spectrum diagram,
and we can see that on this diagram
what people would normally
consider radio waves.
These are some of the lowest frequencies
and longest wavelengths of light.
And then when you get
to higher frequencies,
you get to microwave, and
the higher the frequency,
there's also the higher
the energy per photon.
And then you get higher
frequencies in that
and higher energy, that's infrared,
and then higher frequency and energy,
that's visible light.
That's what our eyes can sense.
And then you get even higher
frequency, and more energy.
You get to ultraviolet. Then
X-ray and then gamma rays.
And this isn't a linear scale.
You can see that this is
a logarithmic scale here.
This is in powers of 10.
So we see some pretty dramatic
increases in frequency
and energy as we go from
the left to the right.
But in this video, we're
gonna focus in particular,
on microwave, infrared, visible
and ultraviolet wavelengths
of electromagnetic light,
or electromagnetic waves,
and think about how they
interact with molecules.
So if we start with microwave radiation,
and here we have a water molecule,
I've picked that right over there
and I can get my simulation going.
You can see what it's doing
is, when it gets absorbed,
it causes a rotational
transition in the water molecule.
It makes the water molecule
rotate in a different way
than it was before.
And then the water molecule
can also emit the radiation
and then rotate differently.
And so you can see it
doesn't always do that.
There's a little bit of
a probability involved,
but this is actually the
basis of how microwaves work,
your microwave oven,
is it causes the water molecules
to get agitated in a rotational way,
which increases the heat in that system.
Now we could also look at infrared light,
which is once again, we have to remember,
gets us into higher frequencies,
and see what that does to molecules.
So based on this simulation,
it looks like the infrared
light is when it gets absorbed,
it causes this water
molecule to start to vibrate.
So microwave radiation caused it to rotate
or to have a change in
state of its rotation,
while infrared makes it vibrate.
And we could see that with
other molecules as well.
Let's try carbon monoxide.
Once again, it's not rotating it,
it's causing it to vibrate.
Now what about visible light?
Well, visible light will
have different interactions
with different types of molecules,
but let's try it out
with nitrogen dioxide.
So there's certain situations
where nitrogen dioxide
will absorb, that's
when you saw it glowing
and what you see when it's glowing,
what it's really doing
is it's putting electrons
into a higher energy state,
or into a higher orbital
and then when it stops glowing,
it means that those
electrons are going back
to a lower energy state.
They are re-emitting radiation.
So there, you can see it.
You can see that just now,
it's remitting visible light,
in this case a different direction.
And when it did that, the
electron that was excited,
went to a lower energy state.
Now what about, let's think
about ultraviolet light,
which has even higher
energy than visible light.
What can that do?
Well, here, we can see that
it takes, in certain cases,
electrons, and it's able
to excite them so much
that it's able to break that bond itself.
And so let me keep resetting it.
So you can actually break bonds.
Let's see what it can do to some ozone?
Same thing, it excites it so much
that it can actually break the bond.
It's exciting electrons so
much. I can keep resetting it.
So the big picture here, the big takeaway.
You could have microwave radiation,
which tends to change the
rotational motion of a molecule.
We saw that with the water molecules.
You have infrared radiation,
which is higher energy
and higher frequency,
which tends to lead to a
change in vibrational motion.
And then you have visible light,
which can excite electrons,
take them to a higher energy state,
and then be readmitted
when the electron goes back
to its base state.
And then you can have ultraviolet light,
that's so powerful, it
can excite electrons
so that in some cases it can
even break covalent bonds.